you
[Music]
I used to work in venture capital and
unfortunately my most well known startup
as a fake one so AI is particularly high
fee as you probably know so during nips
the big AI conference we did a we over
breakfast one day me and my team dreamt
up a company called rocket AI the
technology was called temporally
recurrent optimal learning spell out
troll but unfortunately people missed
that and we made a website and we threw
a party and we convinced all these
journalists I won't name which
publications that this was a real
company we had seven very large
investment funds for an invest in us and
it took a little while it was when
Business Insider kind of tried to write
this this hit piece on us that we
weren't a real company that I revealed
it wasn't a company first but it would
everybody was just a party theme that uh
kind of went off in one direction but
again it's now my most famous
association in the AI field and it was a
drunk joke but uh I guess that says
something about my career actually
actually the best bit about it was not
only what did the police come and raid
the party which says something for an AI
party but we saw t-shirt software's that
said rocket AI with troll on the back
and I made more money off the t-shirts
and we spent on the parties so yeah VC
but I'm not here to talk to you about
fake AI companies although there is some
reference to AI hype in my presentation
I I actually hate public speaking I
think only sociopaths and academics like
public speaking and that's probably a
very fine line between them anyway so
what I decided to do to try and get back
into public speaking now that I am a
technology professional again is that um
I wanted someone asked me to speak in an
event I'll try and give it a title
that's somewhat big enough that I can
when I start making the slides a few
days before which is what I normally do
as I hope everyone else does and is that
I have a big enough title that I can
then think about all the things I'm
interested in and turn that into a
presentation so when where's reached out
to me I get the title leveraging compute
which is definitely theme of this talk
but I added last night the etc to
highlight the fact that I have probably
got ADHD and there is like 20 different
things in this in this comic in this
presentation so I'm sorry that it's not
super hip may perhaps super Karen I
tried Intel
eight months ago I've never worked in a
team bigger than seven and we have
10,000 people in our group 112 thousand
people around the world it's big it's
intense like a country
I started in architectural graphics and
software cuz my background was working
in AI investment and I moved to Silicon
engineering because I just found it
fascinating so I'm very very new to
thinking about that and in terms of
strategies like in engineering I'm not
thinking about how the strategy in terms
of what's on the silicon I'm thinking
about how we should be designing
computers and computer chips for the for
the future five to ten years out so
that's kind of like the theme of this
talk across my many varied interests so
point number one
I think computing has an optimism
problem and here's an example why and
I'm not just shilling for Moore's law
because Gordon Moore is the founder of
Intel I've always been interested in in
Moore's law because Moore's law really
is a self-fulfilling prophecy so Moses
Gordon Moore states in 1965 that the
rate of transistor density will double
approximately every two years and it was
a really a prediction I think that's the
wrong way of thinking about it it was
more that he set a benchmark and then
people thought they could go out and
build it so to me this is like one of
the most extremely powerful examples of
what self-fulfilling and optimistic
prophecies can do in technology but that
doesn't mean to say that people still
think is going to continue so this is I
wish I had it when more iPhones have a
laser
I guess that's very dangerous but um so
here's some examples of kind of like
tech cynicism especially around Moore's
law I think my favorite one is in the
top left everything that can be invented
has been invented in 1899 lots of stuff
about Moore's law dying across across
time really like it goes all the way
back to like 2009 there is nothing new
to be discovered in physics 1900 people
are just really bad predicting kind of
like the limits of progress which is a
kind of another theme of my talk but
they've been particularly bad doing that
on transistor density and Moore's law so
in terms of us safe social contract it's
probably one of the most under
Tomatoes social contracts this is the
kind of multiples that we've had in
Silicon engineering and computer chips
and just between 1980 and 2020 so our
group made this slide and you can see
that Gordon Moore was off by like a
factor of a million so we really tend to
push past what even people predict and I
think the optimistic message about
technology will be the thing that drives
the future if we want it to be so what
has kept Moore's aura alive for 50-plus
years well you have more complexity
because computers are getting more
complicated you have abstraction at
every layer layer you have innovation
but the thing that I actually change
from the original slice this was a
slider my boss Jim Keller who is amazing
and you should fall in him he was
probably the best chip designers the
last 50 years and he he had a he had
refactoring there but I changed it to
belief I think people believing that
Moore's law will continue is the thing
that allowed more to continue because
they believed that was the next
benchmark for what they should design
but most lawyers in just one technology
isn't just simple you know exponential
growth of transit or not that simple
that isn't just transistor gate
transistor transistor density Moore's
law is the kind of like name for what it
is many many different innovations in in
hardware that come together and not just
in hardware but in physics and in math
too that compile to allow for something
that is the increased numbers of
transistors and this is kind of what I
get to learn about every day so when I
moved to work in the silicon engineering
group the reason why I picked it was
that I just got this amazing kind of
like rapid PhD in all these areas of
physics and electrical engineering that
I would never have access to you I'm
still a very nascent in my understanding
of some of these areas but I wanted to
highlight one and that is lithography
which I'm kind of obsessed with right
now so you know lithography is the how
you use lights to define process of
features and by I think you can see in
this image by 2005 they kind of like hit
a wall in in progress at a hundred and
ninety-three nanometers in terms of how
much they could with the resolution of
what they could do and it took 15 years
to get to the current in
they're using in quantity like seven
nanometer designs now which is 13.5
nanometers and this is done by a
technology called
extreme ultraviolet lithography and if
you ever want to be amazed by what
humans can do just in one second to
watch a video and what happens in Eevee
is unreal I fell in love with science
when I went to go tour an Eevee fab but
this is a data science /ai event why
should you care
I think the unsung heroes of AI progress
have been datasets and environments and
access to compute and if you look at a
lot of the kind of breakthroughs in AI
it's really been these two circles that
have allowed for those breakthroughs to
be demonstrated and the person who
really pointed this out in recent time
was rich Sutton here a general read this
paper especially a blog post called the
bit of lesson by Richard Sutton raise
your hand if you read it ok everyone
read it it's so good and so rich sudden
daddy of one of the daddies of
reinforcement learning
he wrote a blog post in earlier this
year that said you know if you if you
look at progress in AI a lot of people
spending time tweaking models trying to
understand you know search and
optimization but if you look at how the
breakthroughs come it tends to be that
something comes along and there's a new
way to leverage compute and it was
really powerful music for me to read
this because I've even published one AI
paper but it was in reinforcement
learning and then to read rich sauce and
he's always been the hero of mine talk
about how even in his own field the the
progress has really come from
computation justified why I had moved
into hardware so so rich Sutton
reinforcement learning here's a brief
history of RL I'm gonna use this as a
case study to kind of demonstrate the
how much compute changes what we can do
in AI so you know it kind of like stems
this kind of reward reward feedback
stems in animal psychology and then it
starts getting interesting again in one
it's interesting for a bit I mean
dynamic programming definitely paid to
it but Richard Sutton and Dawson wrote
the book about reinforcement learning
and then the thing that really kept you
know capital catapult catapulted RL was
in 2014 when when deepmind used it to
demonstrate their RL agents in in the
atari games but again the unsung hero of
that demonstration to me was the arcade
learning environment so we talked a lot
about reinforcement learning in terms of
the deep mind breakthrough but not that
many people give enough credit I think
to 2013 when the Atari games
environments was created to allow for
the agents to be demonstrated in that so
there's one which is datasets and
environments the second thing is on the
other circle is compute so openly I made
this great graph me cuz it meant that we
didn't have to make it at Intel so if
you if you go back to Alex net the
combinational neural network and you go
all the way up to alphago zero you see a
300,000 X multiple in in demand for
compute so that really goes to show just
how much more compute that we're using
for different machine learning paradigms
so here's alphago alphago versus Lisa
doll the last time I was in New York was
three years ago and I was wearing a
t-shirt that was in sporting Lisa dolls
so it goes to show that I'm on the human
side so you know they had and I and I
took this I was researching for this
together date but um I think that there
might have been some TP usage when they
were using this alphago against Lisa
doll but I wasn't quite clear but at
least compute to the same level of
around 1200 CPUs and 176 GPUs versus one
man and one coffee computers is quite
cool so I really think need to start
giving compute more recognition than
then people have been doing and what's
also interesting is the more I've kind
of gone into hardware is look at how
there's like this kind of symbiotic
relationship between hardware and
software so I'm thinking about AI
working in venture capitals starting
fake AI startups and then I go into
hardware and I end up in this meeting
which I just found fascinating which was
you have this problem when you're kind
of doing a silicon design which is the
amount of time it takes like design and
test and validate the chip is is
probably the lead time that you have to
bring out the product against your
competitors so you're always trying to
reduce that time reduce a debugging time
reduce the violation time and one of the
way is that groups have been doing this
this is a group of Intel the
I've been working with is they use
things like reinforcement learning to
actually debug invalidate so it's I
found that interesting to think that
there's like this relationship where
computers allowing for the progress in
the in the AI but then AI is being used
to again reduce the time to debug back
in the hardware ok next tangent section
of my talk progress is weird why am I
saying this
here's Bell's law I think this is really
interesting you kind of have these kind
of arcs of compute classes and that
approximately every 10 years so you know
starts a mainframe now it just because
of Moore's law they keep getting smaller
and more compact and and the reason I
bring this up is that there's this kind
of been running trope for the last few
years that you know progress technology
progress is really slowing down you know
why is why aren't more exciting things
happen and I want to make a counter
example and in this presentation I've
been thinking about this for a while
there then maybe we were focusing too
much on the micro and not thinking
enough about the macros because when
you're in an architect knowledge yard it
kind of seems like a diminishing return
because you don't know what the next law
of accelerating returns are going to
come from so whilst you're in one of
these little micro and curves on these
micro s curves you can't see the overall
kind of exponential growth of the s
curves when you're in Moore's law if you
think about Moore's Law run transistors
essence density you might have seen that
lithography was going to reach this wall
in 2005 and you wouldn't know that the
arc of UV was coming so from from the
inside from from the micro it can it can
seem like it's ending but I actually
think that progress can be
counterintuitive on the macro and it and
there's a reason to be optimistic so
here's some of the s-curves of computing
different programming languages over
time process design around chips you
know now we have evie architectures each
of these were curves that at one point
someone thought they'd reached the end
and something new comes along so I don't
think that we should just be thinking
that progress is slowing down and
computing I think we should be thinking
about what the next arcs are that are
going to contribute towards the macro
and here's opening I doing another graph
me recently that again saved me from
doing some work
they started plotting the usage of
compute and if you if you see that
they've tracked it's kind of like two
year doubling that kind of follows
Moore's law up to about 2013 and then it
kind of goes up to a three point four
month doubling they say and they kind of
find this in these like two areas of
computer and sorry two ears of compute
and I think it's actually a really
interesting slide because you think well
what happens in 2013 2014 that allowed
for this kind of you know increase and I
really just think it's money and they
say this themselves in the paper which
is that you know you start getting more
money into a field there's more of a
drive an economic drives I build better
hardware to support the new startups and
the new companies being brought out and
I think that deepmind prepaid a large
part in this because do you mind got
acquired by Google it started to show
people that kind of research AI groups
had a had a high value and it meant that
startup money kept going I mean I prove
this with Roc AI right we created a fake
company and all these venture funds
start invest in us where the money goes
the growth goes to so you really got
think about from the economic standpoint
and Marie Shanahan from from England he
made this comment about that the year
2014 which was a it was a year when a
childhood passion became a global
obsession and I really think that he
looked back to the recent hype cycle of
AI it does really go back to what was
happening around there with deepmind's
valuation and so economics pushes growth
this is Jevons paradox this is actually
applied to a fuel usage which is the
idea that you know as fuel becomes more
economical then we'll just use less of
it and actually what happens is that
people just end up using more I think
it's a same for compute compute will
just get better they'll get cheaper
you'll get faster but the demand for it
will always outpace the the innovation
in that sector next tangent does
complexity kill progress I bring this up
because I watched this presentation I'm
an advisor to a distributed personal saw
the company called other if you don't
know check it out and born of the
engineers that sent me this talk this is
Jonathan Blow video game designer the
guy behind braid and it's a talk I think
it's called a
Banting civilization collapse has anyone
seen it it's really good
so I watched it like seven times it's
really it really hit me and I came to
the office and I said to everyone I've
seen this talk it's the best talk I've
ever seen and it kind of talks about how
software is becoming more complex and we
depend on it and he's trying to show you
that from the insight from the arc of
the software from what she's observing
in the in the s-curve it that it looks
like that it's a it's it's on decline
and he's got a point I have my own
version of how I've interpreted it his
talk better this is the lines of code in
millions between different programs so
you know version 1 of UNIX not that many
total Google web services now as a 2
billion but that covers so much but
there is a lot of complexity now in in
software and again for the amount of
executed lines of code per written code
so then the kind of narrative becomes
well software is in decline and our
standards for software
and getting lower and I think that's
true but I think there's another way of
interpreted to interpreting it which is
that yeah complex systems are
complicated maybe we need to get over it
- maybe this is the wrong crowd but we
have too many expert Python programmers
and too few generalists but that's okay
because generality is tough and I try
and learn as much as I can about how
computers work at every stack and Intel
and it's just endless computers are so
complicated now that you have people who
actually understand full systems I mean
people that Intel they only know there
are a little one bit I mean some people
obviously know more you'll get told off
for saying that but but the idea that
people could understand the interest in
Trinity is of like the entire compute
stack is is unreal now that as computers
have gotten more complicated so then the
argument becomes do we need a revolution
in computing and you kind of see a
doesn't there's another presentation
that a Jonathan Blow referenced here and
his his YouTube talk which is more in
his presentation which is the thing is
called a 30
line code problem or what it's called I
was trying to link to it at some point
but uh it kind of presents as argument
there's a lot of people saying like okay
software's got complicated we need to go
back to first principles and it makes me
laugh a bit when I hear this some
science because it kinda reminds me of
Communist China and I spelt computer on
on purpose because I do this sometimes
at work which is that this like should
be like one computer it's gonna run more
like you know we've just got this like
one better instruction set that replace
x86 and we could all just move together
on this one paradigm and go forward and
all be in agreement in a centralized or
decentralized way I'd say that Erb it
was going for that kind of decentralized
way then you know progress would happen
a lot better but the counter-argument to
that which which I'm gonna go into is
that it's kind of amazing how much stuff
we've done with all this legacy code and
it's just like unreal to me that what we
can be cynical about it that like you
know it's bad it's complicated and we
don't know how computers work it's also
kind of amazing that we get by and we do
it every day and it's also maybe kind of
up to us
code quality is somewhat of the
leadership problem we don't want to get
our hands dirty and debug across the
stack we're so used to programming there
being problems and it's just wasting our
time and you know maybe wasting our time
is a bit of efforts like we used to
software not working which is one of the
comments that Jonathan Blow had it's a
bit like democracy we don't just go and
fix it we'll just keep compiling the
problems while compounding problems but
there are other industries and there
other complex systems that they don't
have this as an issue for instance
aerospace aerospace is a very complex
system you have different vendors
different providers you have many
different layers of technology and lots
of legacy code and in 2017 my mind that
there was no eight highest years of a
commercial passenger jet and that's
despite there being more flights than
than ever before and I think this is a
good analogy sometimes for programming
and computer science as a whole that you
know aerospace engineers just can't let
it be so shitty because otherwise people
die and it cost billions of dollars
which is not the thing that we have to
deal with every day when we're building
remember building codes so my argument
against
the that software is is in decline is
that maybe software is in decline but
maybe the answer is that we've got to go
in and fix it and get our hands dirty
and this was like the first mean that
came up when I searched to get your hand
study that wasn't pornographic okay so
maybe we don't need a revolution in
computers but maybe we need a revolution
in a IBS raqqa day I was a good example
of how ridiculous it was I think you
were listed I won't name the company as
one of the top 20 breakthroughs in AI in
2017 with a not real technology and
people have been talking about AI yes
for a long time
here's actually my favorite AI paper
it's written by Hubert Dreyfus in 1965
and he goes through he talks about
different benchmarking issues and the
problems with kind of having this kind
of like narrative a narrow way of doing
performant performative benchmarking and
in machine learning and you know things
haven't reach ange that much since 1965
so modern AI as we have both compute
access to compute and datasets and
environments allowing us to create
breakthrough demonstrate breakthroughs
we're also able to hide behind them
compute and datasets and environments
allow us to demonstrate stuff that
actually isn't that general tool that
can seem general and here's an example
and I mean I really like opening I but I
just wanted to give the the dota 5
example as one is that you know notify
train on 45,000 years of game play out
of more than 100 characters in dota they
only had they only had 16 and then once
the once it was like publicly available
for non for like non champion humans to
play against it very quickly humans were
able to figure out how to beat it that's
because bring in the general and these
software agents aren't and it's problem
is tech presses is quite stupid and they
write these like flashy headlines I'm
glad that I don't know if the New York
Times CTO guy is still here New York
Times is ok and I wanted to give that
credit Cade Metz is actually quite cool
so but most the type press is just
terrible and I know that because again I
started a fake AI company and got
pressed for it
here's Barney pal he is an investor and
a good friend here
PhD thesis in 1993 which I love we was
talking about how games as benchmarks
for machine learning a pretty poor
because the only thing that we do is
show that the that the program is able
to demonstrate within a very narrow
framework of a game it doesn't mean that
it can generalize but however they'll
present people will present it as if
that there's some sort of level of
generality so if you're interested in AI
does anyone read this paper and it came
out the other day no oh yes wise but I
read this paper actually on the someone
sentence me I read on the flight here
and I always thought that so France
watch today is the founder of chaos but
I was found him kind of annoying on
Twitter so I never wanted to read it
even though he only just came out but I
read it and it just respawns
everything I loved about computers and
machine learning it's such a good paper
I already hope that people read it he
just it could be ten papers in one paper
it's so darn brilliant he does a kind of
critique of past and present AI
benchmarking so different things that
people have used games and the different
things that big tech companies have used
to demonstrate their agents and their
programs the other thing he does is he
kind of goes into psychology he he
redefines what he thinks as the is the
right explanation of what intelligence
should be in terms of generality and
then for like math fans like like me he
then uses algorithmic and face
information theory to quantify how to
generalize how to generalize how to
quantify the difficulty of the
generalization like how do you how do
you test for kind of like the broad
skill sets and then and then at the end
if that wasn't enough he provides a
dataset a link to I get hardware you can
kind of like test out your own agents in
his new scale for for intelligence it
really is a fantastic paper and he
reminds me kind of of the old AI paper
so just don't really exist anymore
so I'm jontron like there's 70 different
things what are my main takeaways I
think we need optimism in computing
again and not just [ __ ] hype I don't
think Moore's always said it's only dead
if you want to believe instead and then
we won't start building the technology
that we need to make there be better
pootis data and compute fuel AI progress
but we also hide behind them progress
can look like it's slowing and declining
at the micro but from the macro it can
be an exponential growth we just can't
see it as engineers people need to get
their hands dirty and fix things and
also create incentives for other people
to fix those things should read shows
paper and very much his point about
algorithmic information theory is that a
who here knows who Claude Shannon is
love Claude Shannon
so I don't think we have enough
generalists now but I think Claude
Shannon is an example of an amazing
journalist and actually he's like the
father and his mate in theory but uh but
like just like nai there are too few
journalists and his Hubert Dreyfus in
the paper alchemy and AI which I
referred to earlier quoting something
that Shannon said in 1965 and I love
this quote so much because he said this
not as a necessary hardware guy as you
know already thinking of it as a
mathematician but he says can we design
a computer and whose natural operation
is in terms of patents concepts and
vague so our similarities rather than
sequential operations on tangent numbers
and that's why I like to think about
every day and I hope that more people
who think about software and data
science and and machine learning will
talk more with people who are working in
hardware because we really need better
conversations between the two thank you
[Applause]
[Music]